no one looks more desperate than the
person who's constantly seeking the
approval of everyone around them yeah
the irony of that is the people who tend
to get approval who seem tend to look
cool and get the respect are people who
don't really care about whether or not
you respect them they behave how they
behave and if you respect it then you
respect it if you don't doesn't really
matter to them
foreign
have you ever seen a quarter million
dollar handbag
why does this bother me so much take a
look at this video
what are some of the rarest bags you
guys have right now
one of the rarest bags we currently have
in stock is the creme Medela Creme of
Hermes Birkin bags it is the Himalayan
Birkin bag and this is gonna set you
back like the price of a condo this is
brand new with stickers and it is
actually a better deal than most resale
sites we have it here for an amazing
price of 195 000 Canadian whereas some
sites will sell this for over 250 000
Canadian dollars and we don't only have
one of these we don't have two of these
we have three of these in stock we have
it in the Birkin and we have it in the
Cali
I'm not sure why this bothers me so much
by the way let me know in the comments
if it bothers you but TK maybe you can
shine a light on it onto my psychology
why does this bother me
um
I'm gonna ask a couple of questions
that'll help us get there
do you feel like she ought to be using
that money towards something else no no
I
although maybe there's some residue from
that that money would be better spent
now I can say this if I had that bag and
of course I'm not going to buy a Birkin
bag but let's let's put into some other
material possession that a a a quarter
million dollar watch I don't even wear a
watch but I could see a world I used to
wear expensive watches at a Rolex and a
tag viewer like I had watches that were
expensive and back in my corporate days
that's not the best use of that money
for me I'm not even saying it's not the
best use of that money for someone else
maybe what bothers me and unpack this
with me maybe what bothers me is
it's the
false desire the memetic desire created
by this sense of scarcity and Prestige
and status you believe her
consumer choice
represents or reflects some broader
mindset and culture
such that even if not everyone can
afford to act like her that's how most
people or many people think they should
act well there's a lot of teenagers now
I remember I got a job when I was 13 at
Americana in Middletown Ohio and I was
making 425 an hour and I use my whole
summer working 40 plus hours a week use
my whole summer paychecks in a day to
buy the freshest clothes on when the
Tommy Hilfiger jacket and the Ralph
Lauren and the polo and the Nautica like
this is the 90s mid 90s and um I'm
wearing like the freshest clothes back
to school right but now like that is
considered low brow now it's like what
about Gucci what about Prada
what about Balenciaga
well if you don't have Louis Vuitton who
are you even right and it's making
people feel inadequate because I'm going
to put myself up on a pedestal and I
carry those possessions onto the
pedestal to show you how high up on the
pedestal I am and yeah I'm bothered by
that
um
it's interesting because
I always wonder when I see things like
this online
how much of the real world is reflected
by it obviously these companies are in
business and they're getting paid and
there's a strong customer base they're
not going out of business next week but
then I come from a space where in the
South Middle America you just don't hear
that kind of talk people might even make
fun of you for having something like
that that's right whereas here in La you
see it a lot either everybody has it or
everybody's looking up to the people
that have it or feeling bad about
themselves for not yet being able to
afford it and trying really hard to
hustle on something so that they can get
it so it's kind of interesting you know
just like cultures and where that's
prominent and how popular that is yeah
and I think that's really what bothers
me here it's the culture of not enough
you don't have enough unless you have
the things that signal you have enough
no and maybe that's ultimately what my
problem is here my problem is that I
know that I have enough you have enough
in fact if you're listening to this or
watching this you probably have more
than enough and the way you get to
enough isn't by buying the Birkin bag
isn't by buying the Louis Vuitton shoes
or the Gucci belt those things won't
complete you in a way they will
incomplete you they will separate you
from people who you can otherwise
connect with and I think what happens is
we use our material possessions not to
connect with people as a tool to connect
with them but to disconnect ourselves to
make someone else feel inadequate
therefore I can feel adequate oh yeah
that's that's a very interesting point
because you could say there are two
kinds of luxury some things are
luxurious because they are made of the
kind of material or they require the
kind of effort that makes them expensive
there are simply things in life that
takes so much time and energy that they
are expensive by nature but then some
things are luxurious for no other reason
than that they are priced in a way that
limits access and what you are really
buying is not the quality of materials
but you are buying the right to say I
get to be one of the few people who
drive this who wear this who own this or
I can be comfortable knowing that a
certain type of person will never enter
in this space and that's kind of like an
interesting kind of luxury where there's
this Market to buy something that really
amounts to hey I'm one of the few people
who can buy it because what good is
having more money than other people if
you don't get to use it in a way that
sends a signal to them that hey I got
more money than you oh fascinating you
know I really appreciate Beauty and
sometimes the things that are beautiful
do end up being really expensive but the
our idea of beauteous perspectival the
last two or three days there's been this
van parked in front of my house
but don't worry it's not like a spy van
I don't think it's the FBI I hope not
I'm worried it's but it's an old like
1993 Ford Aerostar van and it is a work
of art and I think the average person
who were to walk past it would be like
oh look at this but I look at and I
Marvel at it every and I look at the
it's like it looks like it was made in
the 60s by like Braun or something you
can see there's this engineering design
that went into the form of this van that
I don't see much of anymore and it's
incredibly simple it's aggressively
understated and there's this beauty that
I see that isn't because it's saying
look at me look at me look at me in fact
it's the opposite it's not trying to be
looked at and that's why it is so
beautiful it's utilitarian it's Stark
and I appreciate those things I think
the average person walked past it would
be like oh when you're gonna upgrade
your van but I walk past and said wow AI
you know what I'd kind of like to own
this I like to drive it I like to
because to me it was so understated not
in a way where it's I'm trying to Signal
through understating but I appreciate
its beauty regardless of whether or not
other people think it's beautiful that's
so good one of the dangerous things
about about watching videos like this
for me is it can be real easy to look at
this kind of stuff and then snobbishly
be like that's how rich people act but
I'm not like that there is nothing in me
that is like that and one of the reasons
why I think it's a bit oversimplified to
quickly assume that money changes people
is because more often than not money
simply gives people the freedom the
permission and the power to express
things that were already in them before
they had the money but that they just
lacked the option to give expression to
it's like money doesn't make you stop
respecting other people money doesn't
make you talk any kind of way to other
people but poverty can definitely put
you in a position where you can lose
your job if you talk that way which is
why a lot of people think about Fu money
in the sense of they have people they
want to say f you too but they just
don't feel like they can afford it you
give those people a billion dollars
you're going to start seeing an ugly
side to them you're going to start
hearing some honest feedback from them
will money have changed them no that's
what was always in them and I think for
this person and people like it they
represent so many aspects of our common
Humanity that not everybody can afford
to express but that's still late and
that is
I'm not enough until I can have
something that I don't have because my
value isn't determined by my being it's
not determined by my creativity it's
determined by something that I gotta go
out there and get so that I can show it
to other people and then they say oh
yeah I respect you because of the trophy
that's in your hand but of course there
is no shortcut to respect because as
soon as you lose the thing then you lose
the other people's respect there's also
another side of that needing respect is
a type of prison whether it's respect
through the things that you acquire the
clothes that you wear the bag that
you're carrying the car that you drive
the house that you live in how many
bedrooms do I have how many bathrooms do
I have respect me please yeah man what a
prison that you've put yourself in
needing the respect of someone else no
one looks more desperate than the person
who's constantly seeking the approval of
everyone around them yeah the irony of
that is the people who tend to get
approval
who tend to look cool and get the
respect are people who don't really care
about whether or not you respect them
they behave how they behave and if you
respect it then you respect it and if
you don't doesn't really matter to them
yeah you kind of respect them because
they don't need your respect
did you enjoy this Standalone patreon
highlight if so you can listen to full
episodes of the minimalist private
podcast available exclusively on patreon
visit patreon.com the minimalists or
click the link in the description your
support keeps our podcast and YouTube
Channel 100
advertisement free
[Music]